hi i'm lily reinhart and this is the
wired autocomplete interview
[Music]
i'm still on it i'm here after six
seasons going on seven still on
riverdale
[Music]
okay
does lily reinhardt actually sing in
roto yeah that's me uh against my will
singing i wouldn't choose to sing but i
do sing and i do i do enjoy it on the
show does lily reinhardt have tattoos i
do i have
one
two three four
five six six six going on multiple many
more in the future my favorite one is
probably this one that i got done in
vancouver by a lovely artist named kaiju
she also did this one does lily
reinhardt live with madelaine madeline
and i did live together season one of
riverdale in vancouver we share an
apartment together and i have
quarantined in vancouver twice with
madeleine and cammy and that was fun
does lily reinhardt respond to fan mail
no
but we do get a lot of fan mail sent to
our riverdale office and we don't get to
see all of it but we definitely do see a
good chunk of it but i think it would be
a little hard to respond to all the fan
mail but we do appreciate it does lily
reinhardt have a youtube channel i do
not but i have guest starred on
madeline's youtube channel
how did lily reinhardt
start acting i started by doing local
community theater then that slowly
progressed into me auditioning for local
film and tv in cleveland and then we
kind of just expanded from there i mean
i always wanted to be an actor so i
always was the performing kid in my
family and really wanted to do something
with that growing up and as i did
theater that drive and ambition just got
stronger and stronger who did lily
reinhardt
voice in the simpsons fella ella that
was fun a dream for my dad i grew up
watching the simpsons with my dad and
not understanding the humor at all but
knowing that it made my dad happy and
laughed so i was like yeah we love the
simpsons so
emily reinhardt glamour speech i did a
sp a very scary speech for glamour in
new york a couple years ago wrote the
speech on the notes on my phone a couple
weeks prior but that was very it was
intimidating i had like one of those pop
star microphones i felt like i was
giving a ted talk which i kind of was
it's about body image and stuff like
that in the industry and
people seem to like it so
cool
where did lily reinhardt grow up bay
village ohio i'm a cleveland girl
did lily reinhardt go to the met gala i
have gone i believe three times i feel
very fortunate to go to such a lavish
event feel very out of place there but
it is fun this most recent met gala i
went to in 2021 it was on my birthday
which was fun but i wore a dress by
christian siriano and it had a flower
from all 50 states because the theme was
america something something about
america so he decided to put the flower
of all 50 states so there was a pine
cone on there don't know where but it
was on there was lily reinhardt
in hustlers i was thank you so much for
noticing i was in there it was very
intimidating working on hustlers with
such big names and movie stars so i felt
a little out of place there but i was
just i was just happy to be there and
texting the director at the end of every
day asking am i doing okay am i good am
i gonna get fired because i was feeling
a little insecure but the girls on the
set made me feel so welcomed and and
that was it was a really fun experience
are lily reinhart and timothy chalamet
friends i believe we're friends we
filmed a movie together when i was 18
and we do keep in touch with you saw him
at coachella i was like hey demi he had
his security guards and he was like oh
give me a hug whatever but um he's a
great guy
okay
is lily reinhart
a twin i mean maybe
uh no i'm definitely not i have no idea
why people would think that i have two
sisters i'm the middle child and we do
look a lot alike so maybe that's what
maybe that's why people think that is
lily reinhardt german i am reinhardt
pretty german i think reinhardt stands
for pure heart something like that we
wanted to maybe get like a family tattoo
but my mom doesn't want to get a tattoo
so it feels weird to if we all did it
without her but maybe we'll force her
someday is lily reinhardt related to
john
weirdly people do liken me to her they
say that i look like a young joan cusack
and i don't maybe necessarily see it but
i'm cool with it is lily reinhardt
still on riverdale i'm still on it i'm
here after six seasons going on seven
still on riverdale
i love betty i will really miss playing
a character that's been with me for so
long i mean i don't know how my career
is gonna look but i don't know if i'll
play a character for as long as i've
played betty so i cherish getting to
know her for for that long
okay lily reinhardt poems
i did publish a book of poetry called
swimming lessons and i'm shy about it
and you know feel a little it's like
opening your diary a little bit so that
was a very vulnerable thing to do but um
i'm a very big fan of of poetry i think
i've been writing poems since i was
maybe 16 when i first was falling in
love for the first time and experiencing
long distance love and going on tumblr
to find romantic typewriter poetry that
i could send to my boyfriend so that's
kind of how i first
got into it
lee reinhardt covergirl commercial i've
done two and one of them was shot in my
backyard i filmed it by myself during
covid so that was a very strange
experience to film what i knew was going
to be a national commercial completely
on my own in my backyard but it turned
out pretty good so you know happy with
that
right here look both ways trailer this
is it exists look both ways my film that
comes out august 17th on netflix since
in the look both ways trailer you see
natalie's life splits off into two
different paths i would like to think
that in a parallel life i live on
a farm in hawaii and i sell coconut ice
cream on the side of the road that
sounds like a dream so i hope that
that's where i'm out somewhere in the
universe doing that sounds pretty
fulfilling to me
lily reinhardt tumblr
yes i had a tumblr i i don't remember
how old i was when i started maybe 15 or
something i first started posting like
advice about the acting industry very
cringy i think i deleted all those posts
thank god i also posted fashion like
pictures from the red carpet events
actresses that i loved their dresses
stuff like that and then i posted a
couple poems on tumblr before i
published my book and when i was getting
good feedback from my poetry on tumblr i
think that's what encouraged me to
to publish
lily reinhardt best friend well i have a
best friend her name is austin
and we've been friends since we were 11.
so over half my life now this girl's
been in my life and love her to death
okay
what
time whoa was lily reinhardt
born people were asked this question
that's so weird i believe i was born at
11 15 a.m
but you can ask my mom she doesn't know
entirely but that's the time that we go
with
what
oh
i was like what breed am i what breed is
lily reinhardt's dog milo is a
schnauzer mini schnauzer terrier mix and
he's perfect what episode was lily
reinhardt on law and order i believe it
was season 14 of law order i
don't want to spoil it but definitely
play
creepy creepy young girl
what
skincare
does lily reinhardt use i have such an
assortment of skin care i'm a skincare
junkie i love augustinist bader
renee vello
tatcha we could go through all the
brands love love love skincare
it's interesting to see what people
google i mean i certainly didn't expect
some of those but i'm happy people are
interested enough to want to know things
about me i'm like cool i'll answer these
questions for sure thank you for
googling me i hope i'm interesting
enough if not oh well i'm interesting to
me i guess thank you bye
[Music]